la cámara de diputados de argentina vota
para decidir si aprueba el acuerdo
alcanzado entre el gobierno de alberto
fernández y el fondo monetario
internacional que reestructura la deuda
de 45 mil millones de dólares adquirida
por el gobierno de mauricio macri para
que entre en vigor es necesaria la
aprobación del parlamento argentino y
posteriormente un nuevo respaldo del
organismo internacional el pacto divide
tanto al congreso como a los ciudadanos
este es el mejor acuerdo de
refinanciación que se pudo conseguir el
rechazo de este acuerdo que sería el
default nos llevaría a grandes problemas
económicos sociales e institucionales
que estoy convencido tenemos que evitar
a toda costa es un acuerdo de coloniaje
sólo puede traer más crisis más ajuste
más pobreza y que preanuncia las
condiciones de una rebelión popular como
en su momento ocurrió con los acuerdos
con el fmi en ecuador
[Música]
mientras se discutía el proyecto habían
manifestaciones a las afueras del
congreso
ciudadanos movimientos sociales y grupos
de izquierda lanzaron piedras quemaron
banderas cauchos y basura para expresar
su desacuerdo con el pacto
para hacer frente a sus obligaciones con
el fondo monetario internacional los
gobiernos anteriores de argentina han
tenido que recortar planes sociales por
lo que los ciudadanos temen que se
mermen aún más las ayudas